all right and we are both live I think
hope so
happy Good Friday people what is going
on it has been a minute the last word
with Cognito any Boches returns from my
hiatus how are you doing sir doing
pretty good
better crazy about 12 hours to make sure
we could actually get this thing in and
honestly just fighting with my internet
so it's one of those weird things where
it was weird I tried to get everything
squared up so streaming was good and
then like my download speed is solid
like I have a pretty solid connection
there but my upload speed was like less
than one I was like alright this ignore
those absolute trash so I was like
trying to reset everything and it's one
of those things I didn't even think
about I don't know if it was just the
computer or what but I like did
everything reset of the router reset the
computer I feel like I redid everything
and then finally later after I like I
went to just literally my internet login
and had them like ping the ping my modem
through their web portal and like I was
like okay let's say I was walking to my
house checked with my phone as like to
actually work like I had them do
everything on there and I did everything
else and then finally that stupid thing
works so Wow because we have seen some
delays may have seen some questions if
this was gonna happen but apparently
just me handling I was flying it's the
second time it's happened so I'm looking
up like a cable guy came out today this
issue yeah oh you having this issue
before time so I'm still gonna have the
guy come out and like check or clean up
the signal who knows but I just wish I
can pay for faster uploads cuz right now
I can get which again right now and you
upload 20 yeah cuz today I'm assuming
your downloads really good my downloads
400 which is like more than enough like
I mean you're solid like that's gonna do
most of what you need and no investor
than a lot of people's but up being
maxed at 20 and the sad thing is even if
I got to go to gig down my upload only
goes to 40 I'm like seriously Wow yeah
even like it even if it was like a
hundred up I'd be good sadly I got to
experience my brother's Internet in
Austin and it was like down and up I did
my video with my nephews that once I
made it over the holidays that thing was
uploaded in like 30 seconds it was
insane
it's like I would love that so much how
you been hey that's it's been rough man
I can't even lie to you man you know
it's been a lot of personal things going
on yeah definitely
yeah man you know we put the Lord to
arrest one of good friends of mine
salute low whiskey and I was tough I
lost my heart and then I had some
personal things I had a procedure done
so I'm just kind of like getting back in
the mix and um we're just good to talk
games you know I'm saying like just to
see what's going on in the gaming sphere
and like blue dash or space so it's good
man it's good to be back good to be
feeling like myself you know what I'm
saying and I'm just getting back to the
swing of it all this kind of stuff is
kind of therapeutic for me to get my
mind off the negativity that is one of
those things like sometimes just on a
random note like mm-hmm
people may give me video games crap so I
know they're growing in more popularity
and some people still think gaming is
kind of a nerd thing but for some people
the escapism of games is the real thing
like and that's one of those to where
everybody has like different games you
like and other things like that and
there's the bay debate of like the SEC
euro easy mode and all those things
going on around or people give in
certain modes a hard time or is this
game fun there's this DLC crap it's like
just have fun I mean that's where I want
to start today it's like have fun enjoy
it life's too short don't worry about it
exactly that's what it's about
I said literally what it's about and for
me personally like video games have
always been there's been a gym and video
games
always been the two that saved me you
know those are my distractions those are
my happy place to get you out of the
whole negativity of anything that's
going on it like you say you gotta have
fun that's what it's about
so yeah we got it we got a lot to talk
about I'm excited you know so let's just
get into it man yeah so it's been a
couple weeks so I know last week was Ark
week was Ark week basically so um we
didn't get to talk last week I talked a
little with my brother but I mean you're
in here now so what are you what were
your thoughts on Ark week for what you
even got to see since we haven't had an
official last word here
I mean my daughter aqua is a little
different I probably I don't know I
think we may differ on this one I don't
know what you're gonna go with this but
I'm like for me off week was really
special because um I enjoyed like you
know me when I get meta changes I go
crazy so you've given me all my old
sunglasses
new life I ran stormcaller like crazy
and with great results you know I ran
top tree I did my chain lightning ping I
felt really good you don't say I felt
really powerful and then I believe one
of the perks to extend this to be the
super lasted so much longer I was tested
against yellow bars 150 percent damage
buff feeling nice you know I'm saying I
do that on with like crown of Tempest
felt good I did bottom tree because I
was playing against some people in the
crucible who were running bottom tree
and the arcs holes last longer and like
you can really hold down space you know
you can really control space and that
felt good so I felt like that was like
the survivor ability kind of a build so
I was just messing around with that but
um as a whole the event was really light
it wasn't really I mean yet thunderlord
came back but I mean I already had it so
it wasn't too much for me but I was
telling friends like yo this is the week
if you don't PC you don't have it get it
you know that kind of thing but um the
event itself was light but for me
personally because I'm biased towards
changes I liked what they did is for me
so um
mm-hmm okay was it a sandbox patch or
was it an event in my case it was
sandbox so this was like what's like
that leg that was kind of the big thing
I talked about with my brother last week
a little bit was it was a glorified say
it was a glorified patch it was not a
spark week there and they're like oh
we're gonna have our counties literally
like Zavala and shacks head yes one
bounty and then you had they just that
was one of those that I feel like had so
much more it had a lot of potential like
I mean you can do so many different
things with that arc sage could
literally be everywhere maybe arcs in
schism crucible you're on a level
playing field it's not like this week
which is a totally different matter
we'll get into in a little bit but you
could have like arcs engine raids or you
can have arc
image for you doing 100% extra damage
everywhere just to like mix it up for a
week they had Lake so many different
options potentially right now their game
works on the back end but like the singe
and things like what if you even patrol
had it like patrol Hedison users go
around it just absolutely wreck stuff
for lost sector anything else like
anything else besides I mean I don't
mind the sandbox patches those were good
like sadly it took how long to get those
it took awhile sadly you know what I
mean it was good because you love trip
feed content I bought this is what you
want
I never said sandbox patches need to be
drip fed we nice liked about I talk
about the sandbox
0:03 we got a sacrifice you know I'm
gonna start to get back into it yeah
it's just I guess that was the big thing
about Ark we won't spend too long on it
like it should be on the roadmap and non
have more to it like they knew what this
was a a while ago because you know they
do their data and they do their
adjusting and they do their testing like
this is a thing for a while and it's
just if they would have set expectations
and be like hey this is an art focused
sandbox patch like that could have been
a different way to phrase it
as opposed to Ark week and everybody's
like what's our quick what could it be
could it be yeah yeah anything so it was
awesome no I didn't like it was
lackluster for it should not have been
on the roadmap I think that's the
biggest thing they they hyped it up if
you can't compare the revelry versus
that and they're sitting right next to
each other on the roadmap
no I we gonna get into it it was funny
that probably gonna be I'm gonna
surprise you about my answers in
comparison with those two events but I
said listen you're completely right like
the way they made it seem was like
something was going on and literally
like you said you go to shacks and it
was like one more bounty I mean it's
just a body changed to Ark yeah that's
all the match the week that's it yeah
that's it like there was the way they
were making it seem like we're gonna
talk to every vendor and it would be
these specific brownies and it would be
yeah I mean their hottest excite to the
drifter like them mo like literally the
moat was the hottest thing for the event
you know
not even event I don't even consider it
an event yeah it was just a sub class
patch you know there that's it so yeah
it was just like this week something
funny happened on the way to Ark week or
whatever it's like an ark it's just that
it didn't feel just shouldn't have been
called that so it's like sandbox changes
things like that wave splitter found its
way into PC for a second oh yeah quickly
nullified due to contracts I'm sure it's
out of their hands that works so yeah
people can have waves splitter but it's
not of no use currently so that's out
there right
shout out there putting chat this
morning thank you guys for tuning in for
the early podcast by the way so people
were fought like the pinnacle weapon
break by the way did you see about that
- no no there was a way to like pick up
the pinnacle weapon like I don't know if
you could delete it reap ick it up or if
you hadn't picked it up yet you could
over pick it up basically you could pick
it up over and over and over and it was
always the full master work so people
like picked up like nine and broke it
down I got master of course so people
got like 2000 master workhorse and like
broke the economy know about this hustle
Wow it was only up there for literally
hours I like so a video about it and
then they did like a server-side peace
on their side so where you couldn't like
acquired until they fixed it so oh they
did a server-side patching it was able
to fix something quick yeah Wow I wished
I could do something with something else
we gonna talk about yeah exactly so yes
if that was a thing and then
century armor gettin turned off for a
couple days they did actually get that
turned back on
it was just like basically it was kind
of a broken perk where you could have
the armor on get the perk and then you
turned it off you kept the perk for like
the entire match if you didn't die and
you get absolutely just like destroy
prime evils or something like that so
couple issues happens they were fairly
quick to kind of respond and adjust work
possible and we'll talk about some
things they still haven't quite adjusted
quickly to and that's the other piece
with like the sandbox patch we still
don't have anything with regards to
spectral blades now we get a little like
you Tate will talk but go tidbit and I
was like I'm even looking at the number
and I still question if it's enough the
way that thing feels but yeah as like
spectral blades are still just rampant
out there it's still crazy oh yeah oh
yeah arc weak kind of a lackluster like
the sandbox patches were cool but it
should have just been hey you know enjoy
these our changes have fun if you want
to call it our quit cool but they
shouldn't have called it arc week so
yeah it's just my opinion I agree I
agree very very lackluster in the bigger
scheme of things
yep now for what is actually probably an
event we have the revelry and that's
starting on Tuesday this is the spring
event and it goes for three weeks what
are your thoughts on it so far what do
you think probably you know mean you had
a mini last word podcast about a day ago
was it we talked someone like yeah so
it's like you know the way I'm looking
at this thing right now and to be honest
you II I'm not I'm not I'm not fin I
like the whole you know the idea is cool
but you know what they lost me will you
reuse the assets from infinite I mean
not well you're using the infinitive for
us again I just want to do something
different so like the way I look at it
is like well this is just almost it was
the haunting what was it called
when we did was it the power think oh
yeah this is the Haunted Forest remixed
you know it now full disclosure I did
not play I watched I saw you stuff you
know I saw you playing I saw you know
what you were doing but um it's not it's
not it doesn't have me engaged it's not
it's not a new activity right yep so
it's like you know that that's the thing
I literally was like yeah and for me and
what we're gonna get into is I was like
look I'm not even worrying about this
thing and here's the other thing like I
really didn't care about the boys at the
are bolused that's their shout out to
you shout that you know asked across all
the guys to put it through the paces
you know because again we were under the
impression based on the these the perk
that it would be the match game kind of
i exotic right this is what you're gonna
use what I was hoping for I really want
yeah
it is like when I'm seeing the stories
of people who finally get it in again
not saying it's the worst weapon but the
potential what we thought it could be it
was not so once I saw it Adam Lang I'm
not crying for that and um you know what
I'm gonna get into you want me to touch
the PvP thing I I can go it's up to you
but yeah I mean just keep this is your
thoughts man just open the door listen
it
I was my full disclosure I was not doing
the river I was like I'm not doing it
árboles seems on lacklustre I'm not
doing haunted forestry do not doing it
I'm gonna stay a cop cuz I've been in a
good Compson as I mean you had discussed
earlier you know I'm saying your boy is
really rockin I had um well I got a good
blowout right now vigilance wing is
really feeling good doing my thing with
that nine hundred subs I got a good uh
bug out bag I got the curated roll and I
had another role but she's actually
really dead it's like a Zen moment and
something else but whatever it's been
doing good and nine hundred subs in
either a kinetic energy we doing good so
I've been in a good calm space while I'm
close to getting Luna on PC so I'll play
and I'm like all right you know revelry
week I'm not paying too much to revelry
I'm just in comp ride a start out and it
was match about like three hunters and
they all has Chernobyl valve this is
interesting
yeah I've never seen this before in
countdown competitive okay so we start
the match and you know I'm about to set
the charge in like literally eighteen
renée's just kept coming down the hall
and I'm like is this ever gonna stop
like what is going on so I was like okay
you know it was so bad II I'm like yo D
hack grenades what did they do
somebody's got a hack they they figured
something now it's gotta be with the
exotic as you know vow it is somebody's
doing something so i sat there and i
said look at you know look at the thing
and people are telling me that they're
using a buff from the revelry that is
giving gum disease some entities
evie be competitive BBB like I'm just
about my mind's boggled on the decision
process so I went to the forums you know
and I saw read it and you know read it
was like yeah you know we wanted to let
you know the Irish I may have been Cosmo
and even like you know I want we wanted
to see how it you know affected almost
hold on I took all please do open this
early I've been looking at that too much
alright so verbatim from Cosmo on reddit
with the revelry we wanted to rejuvenate
every activity in Destiny with the
global change to the sandbox meta that
lasted for a limited time we knew this
would be disruptive apparently not as
much as they thought but we were willing
to try to experiment only last for a few
weeks
it's clear we overshot sounds like they
over nerfed like no but they they they
are so they're so into their data and
everything sometimes just to a fault
because then when they overshoot and be
like oh we really got a nerf Nova warp
into the ground oh we went too far
Siteman and variation to the crucible
especially in competitive we've made the
experience random and frustrating we
don't have the ability to random and
frustrating that's a nice way to put it
I like that Reiko has blank you can fill
in or whatever word you choose there hmm
we don't have the ability to immediately
remove the tonics in competitive via our
servers will continue to investigate
possible changes but this experience
will have to run the duration of the
revelry before we can patch a change
we've learned a lot from the last two
days of revelry next time we make
changes of effective our sandbox for a
limited time well ensure a much much
better experience for the crucible all
right is Dilshad to said free mini chat
listen man I there is no way someone
should have signed off on the fact that
this would be affecting competitive PvP
yeah if you want to say quick play fast
you want to save a mayhem fine right
yeah but competitive PvP you are
allowing a PvE centric buff it's an
excuse
it's inexcusable and now they're saying
because of the way it's set up it can
only be done server-side you know I'm
saying and at the end of the day it's
just like listen I cannot play
competitive I did that the whole
experience is wrong la I'm not
ridiculous right now I'm not doing it
bro so just like for me this event
completely folded me on destiny right
now like all I want to do is play PvP
because I have made a commitment not to
do rebel I didn't feel like doing that
cut I didn't feel like grinding and this
happens so it's just like this is it for
me man I'm back in my home you see
what's going on with division and anthem
like I was man you just look at that one
to jump on I know I see your pain do I
don't know I'm scared this will be just
the random side note so there's a boss
in that game I mean there's a lot of
bosses in that game a lot of them will
break you one of the early ones on is
Guinness hero I'm sure I'm snow probably
saying that wrong then you'll meet him
pretty quick it's not like a big
surprise you're gonna face him in some
way he's the first boss who actually
made me learn like the way that game is
meant to be played and it was a struggle
like I had the one dude seven Spears
just like and I was kind of early when I
found him killed me like 64 times thanks
to twitch for keeping track because I
lost track yeah 64 deaths was crazy but
I will definitely save there is a a
secret boss per se like you would
actually you have to kind of go out of
your way to find it and it's like you
it's it's the way those fights sometimes
go like and this is the word like the
patience comes into play it it's the
game the game is not for everybody I
will totally agree but it's like I
started this fight and just looking at
this like thing that I'm fighting I'm
just like I have I have no idea if I'm
ever gonna be like this feels like
nothing and then like first time like
okay so I got smashed it was like
alright that didn't work and then it's
like slowly but slowly and you have to
the way psych heroics they have like
little dots on top they're like health
like lives basically if you get it down
low you basically take alive and
sometimes they have two or three
depending this one had three I'm just
like only got a three phase fight but I
was like literally sticking with it took
like two hours I got close a couple
times but like all right
my headspace and then like Luda watching
the episode of something with my life
came back let me finish down like the
third fight so like yeah the boss fight
took me two and a half hours but like
that I know that sounds ridiculous for
someone you're like it's all the other
side like each one of those that I kill
them just like a better at the game I'm
smarter I know that's like I know what
to expect then like and those hit it was
I'm not gonna say the name of the boss
in case you haven't seen it just because
when you come upon it I don't even spoil
it in case you just want to keep it
clean but when I got there was just like
oh my god like and it was it just blew
me away and then I it's just I slowly
had to whittle on it like stay back
watch learn the fights get in there get
smashed plenty of times but it's like it
just slowly started coming together and
it's just my mindset from how that
started so how like the fight ended
being like I I can do this clean on
round two okay okay I know this is all
working I got it I got like and just
arting to play smarter and smarter and
smarter it was just like that was just a
really cool experience lately and it was
like just the like the mindset shift of
me in literally three hours on that game
was like there's no way in hell I'm ever
gonna do this and I'm in the middle of
like the final time I fought him and
beat him I'm like alright we got this
all right cool and know what's coming
all right get the dodging and stuff like
that and it was just like it's the the
build and evolution is like it just kept
getting really cool and oh it's
satisfying I see you guys it is it
listen though I have a feeling that one
is all your boy wanted to do was take
his vigilance wing out there boy yeah
boy wanted to do is kill some Guardians
that's all I would do I want to use my
load none of my buffs you don't say I
wanted a nice environment I couldn't do
that I couldn't do destiny couldn't
provide me man because all you evil
hunters out here with noble vows or skip
grenades going crazy making it real
salty and you have to follow this video
about this about fella oh yeah hilarious
it's just like are you really
you want another great have it a couple
over here I'll let this one over here
about a grenade here oh you want another
good okay here how about another good
name
oh you want a couple grenades and it was
just like he was rolling he's like by
the way don't do this mmm he's like yeah
this is real broken so ya know boost val
is probably the worst of all
them just because it's gotten the bounce
tracking if you yes that and that's just
what it's cape coast it will track
around corners and stuff like that and
that's the only one that's literally
like a burn the corner yeah so yes for
like a Titan I can have if I go Halla
fire heart and I'm maximum that grenade
buff like in PvE oh my god I'd never
stop hitting the cue button it's yeah so
I mean like the grenade is really fun in
PvE but yeah like quick play it would
have been like okay this is like mayhem
however you want cool but it was like
competitive that was that was a drastic
drastic mistake
so like stuff that's like go through
random strikes go through the raid like
you could do that type of stuff with
stupid buffs and like that stuff's kind
of fun that's what I think arc we could
have been to is something more of
l'absolu that general overall buff to
everything go have fun a pv but clump
mm-hmm that's it that sidebar like giant
barrier don't break it like because I
mean especially if people are going like
Lunas and recluse and people are working
on their grinds a little rock in for
like three weeks yeah it's absolutely
broken for three weeks crucibles
literally ruined for me and I'm just
like damn I gotta wait three weeks right
I can't you know and again it's just
nothing right now that's exciting me
with the current content you know I'm
saying obviously I've done you know I
mean you talked I didn't realize I
already did you know Tier three
reckoning start light and I was really
honest I really liked reckoning I've
been having a lot of fun building
amperage to tension holding down the
spots you know it's the escalation
protocol still my number one as far as
that kind of horde kind of thing but I
do like the aspect of reckoning and I'm
saying so you know once I did that then
it's like okay cool and mean you again
had this discussion like I'm not the
biggest fan of gambit prime like I
thought I would be I thought I would be
really into it and I think I'm I'm not
gonna say staying it gambit is better
I'm not gonna say that but it's just
something about it I just still feel
it's just still a little bit too over on
invasion heavy and um have you played at
the patch
I have played since patch I play another
better better
it's I don't know what it is I think
what did I think it's when the primeval
comes out yeah it just gets annoying to
me I get annoyed you know say and then
it's something about I feel invaders I
don't know if it's because they have
their full perk sets but like invaded
still feel strong I feel like when it
was in regular gambit I had a couple of
seconds to react or do something right I
feel in gambit crime the minute maybe
cuz snipers are buffed or something like
it is in say like someone got to drop
its over like this no I feel like
there's no chance to kind of counter an
invader that's like a really good sniper
at least that may be this really good
honestly so yeah I mean that's like a
mapping gambit in general like if
somebody's a good sniper in they
actually and that's the point where it's
a they're whether it was the you know
the Z through walls vision was like a
pulse here like okay I know they're in
the area it's not like because it's
literally like the secret walls to know
when they're gonna walk out to like dumb
that shot whether it's you know linear
fusions or snipers it's like having that
constant awareness it's not like the
pulse to be like are they coming out of
and then having to actually react you're
just waiting for them to walk into your
cursor and damn so like that's not a
part about it but I mean like me on the
other side I'll go invade and I will
absolutely get like if they if the teams
like orchestrate and be like hey we got
to we're waiting on the invader okay I
mop over if they look for me I'm done
and I've even got the full invader set
with the buff like I went full invader
but like set and those know if they work
together dude I'm still screwed it's
like I can I can put some work in on my
side I've done plenty of killing like
and I'm not even by any stretch the best
and I've been I've been able to do some
work machine gun range is still crazy
hammerheads like the way to go yeah I
still good
hammerhead still damn good but on the
other side if a team like looks for me
it goes like I go fast I really do so
part of its just like the team's if
you're working together randoms and it's
late it's it's the times where you have
four verse for all singles those times
are when I feel like gambits usually
kind of around it's best there might be
a good invader and I might be decent and
we're kind of trading back and forth and
it all kind of depends on how the teams
come together but for me in the new game
but Prime
I like more than the old maps because
they're in the new maps you do have more
places to hide like especially the mom
yeah yeah like so I was like I really
like the new maps and I wish for one to
like a couple of the maps are not in
gambit which sucks like normal game but
I wish they'd just bring them over but
it just feels like when you go play the
first one the one on etz after playing
one of the new maps it's just like it's
so open and hard - yeah it's yes thank
you it's so wide open the prompt you
nailed it
that's literally what my issue is it's
just so wide open so it's like a
sniper's dream you can't get away and
babies all the new maps like those are
honest yeah a lot better yeah absolutely
I agree because you got like different
quarters to go in like don't want on
Titan is like the big circle so you know
quite no direction but you've also got
like buildings like around for you can
kind of work the circle or go through
corridors like the forest is literally
it's a giant open field - the kind of
buildings in the forest you're like it's
pretty open so depending on where they
spawn you're kind of screwed and they're
bigger maps to both of the projects are
definitely bigger so I enjoy that aspect
of it and like the sets like that
that giant have you seen the giant
blocker yet have you come across that
boy um yeah oh yeah yeah he's a mess
yeah hot mess oh yeah I had one where
they were collector we were working on
protecting him and I was invader they
and this is what my brother talked about
at one point it was he'd send the
collector first he actually starts
draining all by himself then as soon as
that one goes down if we get enough
deposited then I go over with the full
invader set as soon as I invade I shut
their bank down and either I know I like
that mechanic I was like those are cools
like so then it's like I go across shut
their bank down then they're like well
do I hide okay if they hide then I can
go stand by it if I'm brave enough or I
can just be in there and just slow them
down for a while and if I can even get
one or two it's tough so yeah I mean the
giant blocker I've seen him get I saw
there was one point I think four giant
blockers got said yeah but did if you
somebody with a chaos reach just melted
all of them so I mean melted all oh yeah
I've seen it can get melted through but
it's like if you don't have that super
at that moment it's gonna be a brutal
brutal little while so the
pairing of the builds can be kind of
cool my issue is just still like my
actual issue with that
Gambhir crime is a nice evolution in
most aspects of it I like how it's one
around I like how it's a hundred points
I kind of like to have you a couple more
invasions the primeval like mechanics
where you got the two sets of envoys and
then the one for the damage the timing
of that it gives many things a lot more
strategy one of my biggest issues is all
these sets I'm grinding for that I get
from reckoning don't help me in
reckoning yeah so it's like it's so
niche and specific to just that mode and
you want to be a bit yeah it's literally
gambit prime like literally when I
described it at one point I was like
it's one bubble on your director the set
works for one bubble and I'm like not
even normal game but that was like okay
so maybe if I was going to invade maybe
I can't like drain motes because it's
not game but Prime but I could it was my
set bonus have improved invasion shield
right that what's the right I could have
the ammo trickle into me and then when I
come back I can take the damage with me
for the enemies that I killed some play
like three of the four perks would still
work in normal gambit and it gives me a
reason to grind for it and would give
people a reason actually I want to go
check out prime so but just the fact
that like I spend all this time as you
say you enjoy reckoning what yes like
it's fun compete EE the tension on the
bridge which is just absolutely insane
now first of all shout out to the beat
shout out to the beat in the recommend
come on it's kind of got some good oh
yeah I guess and IB I you know I don't
really like what [ __ ] but I see I'm
coming around I'm coming around
recommend yeah I reckon I'll like her
role in there man and she gets me pumped
up and it feels good man it's just
tension build the bridge get over there
boom and then what I like is just you're
fully Unleashed like I got my skull
diamond car I'm like blast and stuff
it's just and you know you got you you
wall out it's doing the thing you got
your tensors it is everyone is useful
and again it's kind of like a deck of
cards like if one person falls but I did
everyone's trying to read
if you don't get that rez or they die in
the run between and you're too far
and there's a big guy between you and
then be like sorry dude it's like we
gonna have to hold down the fort you're
gonna have to run back which if you got
three up you can do it but if one goes
and another goes if you're two you're
done like it's so fast impulse I mean
and that one specifically like you've
said you've had good luck in your
matchmaking like getting good people you
heard with you and it does seem to help
if you get to tier three that people
have an idea I've had been decent look
recently with like me and my brother
will go in like will usually run to
Titans he's run in bubble with saint-14
I'll run the other shield for like kind
of a walking cover and then if we can
get like a war if we can get a couple
hunters or like a warlock and a hunter I
mean we're good to go but if we get just
people that don't quite get the concept
oh it's you can't cross that bridge if
you don't tether like to tethers is so
valuable it's insane oh you like to
Orpheus weak tethers one on either side
you barely even need to do anything
besides manage snipers like yeah so like
it's a load but yeah that's just the
annoying thing is like how I've worked
so hard I got this new set of armor if
it even just gave me like 5% health and
damage bonus per set that I'm peace that
I'm wearing in reckoning to be like hey
you've worked harder in here this crazy
horde mode is somewhat easier so now if
you come in here as like less of a made
team at least you'll be more potent and
survivable in the activity you grinded
it upward like a little piece like that
give me a bonus and a reckoning because
that's where I actually spend the time
to get it it should work in both in
anything so no facts
I completely agree yeah something we got
talking about all that but things
happened but the rebel race so we've got
the forest my thoughts so far so like
shout out to glad first thing he did is
they were getting up to like branch 500
so two things about that and actually
Tassie had a good little article out
this morning kind of about the infinite
force keeps getting closer to what we
wanted like curse of osiris suck because
the infinite force was not the infinite
forest it was like hey here's a doorway
to the next part of this mission that's
all it was it's just like an extended
path so they're getting closer to kind
of these horde modes and things like
that we kind of have this continual
thing but there's the difference of
previously it was like okay you get to
this point you do a boss okay cool you
do it again
and people get farther and farther but
got to the point of being like
exorbitant ly heart they flipped it on
the other side now the enemies are just
kind of normal if you run a decent build
like you know as you were saying skull
of dire hum Cara or Orpheus rake hunter
like if you have those couple people
with you they were going to branch 500
with no stop in sight and there's a
point where like there needs to be a
difficulty curve at some point like
branch 500 should be harder than branch
1 and it's not yeah a shoulder so that's
one piece of it and then the other thing
it's just like what's the point in going
in there so like you have the are
bolused
which is it I mean in my opinion like
cool guy has a pretty good video out
there right now he actually does like
the gun for PvP and for me the
lackluster things we're talking about
match game the way the perk reads it
should have been doing more in PvE
because it says it's gonna do large
damage to shields and it's a kinetic
weapon and when you read the
modification on match game
it says elemental day unmatched
elemental damage non-kinetic by the way
right unmatched elemental damage is not
gonna do very much to shield to forget
the exact terminology I was like okay so
kinetic thing could be really cool if
you have match came out this would be
kind of a fun way to mix up night falls
if you grind out nope like you turn
match game on and it takes for I mean it
does like multiple hits when you hit
them but it still took me four shot like
multiple shots on a red bar shielded
captain multiple shots that management
red bars that come on it's less than 20
bars so I mean and it's kinetic so it's
useless against all types of shields
it's not like it's good against one it's
useless in song now if match game's not
on it is powerful because you can put
them and then like your second shot on a
head versus a captain is like 113,000 it
does a bunker cement and damage when it
perks right but as currently especially
now later on when we get to next season
when we bumped a 750 power level and the
handicap isn't quite as high required
then you could probably go without match
game and have some fun with that one but
right now is match games kind of your
way to get to a four times multiplier
for me is just it's it sucked the wind
out of what I was hoping it would be
like I used it yeah I got a couple
crispy kinda you know fusion Snipes on
headshots and it's kind of cool but like
in as I think cool guy was saying it has
some
if it's where like if you break a shield
and your next one if you turn around and
shoot them again in a body you can't
kill them even a super like if you
headshot him in a super and then body
them that's to the range where you can
kill them with this gun which is some
power to it but it's just the it's a
kinetic linear fusion rifle it does use
special ammo so you'll get your ammo a
lot more which is good but in general
it's not over-the-top amazing which
again we're hyped then it has a very
nice use so no idea very niche are very
good so yeah I mean you've got that
thanks no go ahead
just a cut just couldn't get enthused
man like I just couldn't get up for the
event you know even with the other stuff
we had you know thorn we had last word
and again it's not a godless the worst
thing ever but it's just like you said
it's just very mediocre very lackluster
and I just didn't I didn't feel this
gameplay loop of what they wanted me to
do this you know for this one just
pretty much what it came down to for the
revelry yeah so I mean I had that thing
pretty much day one didn't take that
long there are seven triumphs if you're
like if you're punch and stuff will you
go through the forest do a few strikes
get a couple bounties done
alright generally it doesn't take that
much effort to get if you can kill the
five bosses each time and if you don't
use the buff or even if you do I mean
spend a little longer and there do a
couple runs as long as you're not
spending an hour per run and you'll
eventually get it and it's not back but
we have this thing for three weeks now I
know it's like sometimes the the events
people like hole but I'm out of town
this week and I'm gonna miss it okay
then fine like keep it you know maybe
two weeks but three weeks for this thing
is way too long the second ways there's
no need for it there's nothing right or
wrong it for why is it this long lead
I'm saying like that's a perfect example
perfect example it was not like they
also have multiple things to chase no
there's no say it's like a here's the
the cool armor is it ever verse sadly
mmm-hmm
whatever the vernal growth I think is
what it's called I actually kinda like
the look at that one
the Ornt the antler ornaments are in
that stupid little box at Ava that is
RNG
and I think I forget who in my den I go
to this SK three
one he was telling me he's like he had
500 essence and he finally got it and he
has like free essence now or something
like that so yeah the literally spend
all that essence just to try and get the
ornament for your helm and I don't even
think that buff lasts past the event or
like the cosmetic doesn't even last
after the event and I'm just like if I'm
gonna grind this stuff out at least let
me like enjoy these antlers later on
peeled people can be like hey where'd
you get that oh there was this cool
event yeah as of now the ornaments don't
last past the event as drifter saying
it's just like why why why why do those
have to stop being functional like if
I'm gonna ride it out and like if I'm
gonna have three weeks to like spend
some time in the forest thing getting
all this essence and try and at least
get one of these sets of ornaments let
me enjoy them later there's no reason
that should be short-lived
that's they look pretty but I like no
only working habitat they did the same
for the dawning sparrow I'm glad the
dawning sparrow stopped doing its thing
because the that noise when you drive
the dawning spare around it's just
annoying as hell but Jun ching ching
never see but you see antlers just like
it's a cosmetic glow it's like chroma
just chroma that lasts for three weeks
and like mm-hmm
it was like it's they've had so they've
had some misses lately it's like and
that's why season another drifters
we kind of knew it was a low point they
may have planned this around division
and anthem and all this other stuff
going on to be you know a smaller poll
now on the other side the lore that
we've had for The Drifter the
invitations of the nine those have been
cool just to see the glimpses of this
like continuum Drive story like that
piece I've really started to like kind
of enjoy wait for it now I know sadly we
got the hype of the cinematic in week
one I don't know when the next one's
gonna be but they have been cool like
this last week that kind of broke the
fourth wall which was hilarious yes
so I mean that stuff's been fun and I've
enjoyed that and also like xur finally
getting a little more forsaking
functionality and now the yeah faded
ingram has forsaken exotics in there now
so if you're missing anything start
buying those they're milled and other
stuff but it's like the lure of the
drifter and then they have the if you
guys haven't seen it yet go check out
the season The Drifter of the story of
the drifter
yeah hello / inside so you got Lars bak
and I never remembered the other guy in
there
mm-hmm I got a looker yeah remember I
want to call him out by name you think I
gotta call them out got a call them out
slick it up so you got the writers were
they trying to find there
Blake battle so production lead and then
Lars bak and creatively you've seen them
in videos before sitting next to each
other yeah yeah you see how those guys
have been uh but yeah I mean they're
really hyped about The Drifter and the
lore behind him and what he's talking
about is really really cool
like it's got a chance to like he spit
around one of the oldest light bearers
that we've got in the entire Destiny
universe he's seen some stuff he thinks
there's more stuff comin like building
all the stuff up and this is the stuff
that I hope they continue to work on
because we haven't seen Aldrin we don't
know what's going on with Mars Sauve
Holdren steel now we've got The Drifter
talking with it nine building up all
this craziness like they're setting up a
bunch of stuff I just I really want to
pay off at this point but I mean I
really enjoyed the lore piece of that
for drifter but these these last couple
events for me have been like well for
one one was just a patch one was not an
event and then to wait Lord of wolves
loser can give it to you in the famous
diagram that's what I buy I need
confirmation that last week bro don't
say that drifter because I've been
hunting up in my hunt talking about this
I've been doing them damn spot about is
I don't have the long Lord of wolves on
PC and I need that very very much I'm
walking the Lord must have the Lord so I
need that gun and you're telling me I
need car for me he said I got it last
week from a sir faded in Grand
apparently Wow oh here we go
sound get some shards going bro yeah
post it on Twitter please please all
please put that up so yeah if you guys
need anything from forsaken apparently
hit that gram it's working Oh hate me
I'm hate me on hunting go a short
hunting baby that's it this will be
going wow that's crazy man I submit I
need that gun too mmm
so yeah apparently sir has you hyped up
a little bit if nothing else to get that
young man that's powerful right now like
Lord of wolves is seriously putting out
some damage lately but yeah the Bungie
developer insights definitely check that
one out if you have any interest just in
the lore at all check it out it's really
really cool just there's little bits of
cinematic or like frames from that video
that I want to that I really I'm waiting
for them to show up because there's some
cool shots that I'm like when is this
actually gonna happen if there's one
other cinematic that looks like between
the drifter and the emissary like
there's something that we're gonna see
later on that looks really really good
I grew I'm looking forward to that one
but yeah I mean the revelry is going for
three weeks we've got before is hand
lined out and have some fun crucibles
very busted right now quick plays kind
of goofy and fun but competitive is just
broken you got any more thoughts with
regards to brother yeah the only thing
is you know that we got it that like you
brought it to my attention and it really
scared me in the sense that after the
Ravelry um I know we're gonna talk about
banana necks right but after that I
looked at that calendar and wasn't
really excited about I didn't see
anything else so we're literally April
19th yep right the month of May doesn't
have any man that I saw you know say so
I am concerned mr. Jeff feed you
continue please tell us what's happening
there's really I mean we've got we're at
the point where if you look over season
The Drifter we have seen everything I
mean they're playing as March you got
all the maps the invitations launching
game but nine maps go on April 9th is
art week April 16th through May 6 is the
revelry but yeah May 2 what I've got to
assume is gonna be June 4th for the
launch of opulence if they sit to their
typical schedule in the start of each of
the new month mm-hmm
like June 4th is the first Tuesday so I
mean you've got basically a full 28 days
of nothing nothing it is a little
surprising Oh
from the stand point look I know I'm
teasing about the trip free stuff but
this seems I would be shocked we're
gonna go a whole month without any type
of weekly event or you know we don't got
a faction rally obviously still no um 30
days basically almost 30 days without
some type of theme week of something
based on the content structure and
that's concerning
that's very concern I have never seen
this from them you know I'm saying and I
know usually when you figure the hype
cycle for opulence would be I mean the
way they've been doing it before the
week before so I mean if you go to 'zed
A's like first Tuesday of June is June
4th so I mean we're probably looking at
either May 23rd or May 30th because they
don't tend to give a lot of pre pre hype
to these Annual Pass pieces now they're
probably gonna start talking about some
stuff because we've got new raid which
we're not gonna know anything about
until it launches we've got the six
player match made activity and the
redacted items so right there are things
in that annual pest that they're gonna
want to start talking about the main
thing when people are going out to I
don't know when the community sub it is
if it's now or if it happened already I
lost track of that one at some point so
I mean people are going out to kind of
see it get a feel maybe get some final
finishing touches so they might be just
using that time to you know iron that
thing out I don't know if they're
looking at what's coming next after
season of opulence but either way maybe
a week or two before the 23rd would be
the first twoth at i would expect a
whole lot to come and then the 30th
would be the final kind of set up before
basically the next season so we don't
have a whole lot yeah that that's a
weird that that can one would think that
during this period there's going to be
certain that yeah like there's going to
be some surprise next week and they're
gonna like say hey you know it would be
nice to be a nice little faction around
but um you know something just some type
of weekly a van or something to get us
you can't I just I find it
hard to believe that they're gonna
really let go that amount of time
without some type of event now saying
I've never seen a phone chat if you
hadn't confirm I can't remember is the
árboles the exotic quest because it's
not really set up in a quest format you
literally just buy the thing but there's
a free free update for everyone that
says exotic quest right I don't because
I know what they I mean that was that
thorn
that's a quest that's a quest path
multiple steps all those things to it
that's fine mhm and then you've got in
the free seasonal update
you've got exotic quests again sitting
up there that we haven't seen yet so I
mean outside of as you said iron banner
which is gonna be over the next month
right maybe there's an exotic quest that
they throw in yeah it's gotta bei mean
there's that I'm not thinking let's that
could be there because I don't know if
the are bolused is considered a quest
right I mean at the end of the day it's
gotta be it's gotta be because there's
no way they can go that link so I think
they probably kick off some type of
exotic quest where they probably dream
freed it but at you know the other day
it's got to be a chase they can't leave
what's just not doing anything there's
no way there's no way yes ah dr. halibut
hello bear there's a classified kinetic
exotic in collection so I'm hoping for
there is something other than árboles
there we go so I mean and it seems I
mean they've truly I mean they phrase
that if they stick with their messaging
last word was a quest slower and was a
quest this free exotic quest for
everybody and then the one next season
we have two more full quest lines that
should be its own thing so that's just
one of my pieces of that maybe one piece
like that'd be awesome if they if they
had something planned of the whisper
level of this kind of secret thing going
if they had anything to that level
that'd be kind of a cool thing to find
for that last little week in between
iron banner and stuff and a reason to
come back yeah I do not want Gjallarhorn
back in the game I do not want it
oh yeah he's on his bowler own thing see
he wants that bad Levin said very lures
it's gonna be another hand cannon can we
get another type of gun oh my god thank
you whether it's a pulse which is what
is in the meta right now I would love a
scout that was actually good oxygen is
may like this even just the van
scout was not that much I don't know
yeah gimme give me another exotic that's
actually like a different meta I am
I'm definitely getting tired of
everything being a I mean I enjoy hand
cannons at times but dude let me have
some other fun it's a bit it's a bit
much it's a bit much bro hell I would
take that back I would add see you want
a hype up arc week that's how you hype
up or yes hi yes a bark week not
thunderlord not a question already had
like add another event in this game
bring a new weapon back give me a quest
to get it give me something crazy to go
through that would have been a fun way
to hi Park week and then let that quest
go for like another few weeks or
something like that fern they season but
right now ya know so yeah I was like
we're looking at the calendar and we're
trying to figure out what what remains
in until they tell us something I don't
know but that's that's one of those
times where that's one of the reasons I
started this discussion this way it was
to say if you're not having fun if this
like if comp is broken or if you're not
enjoying the revelry or whatever it is
there are so many other games out there
right now take a breather clear your
head of destiny and sometimes and
honestly sometimes with destiny that's a
good thing because we we live in the
world of destiny especially people like
us who are in here all the time and then
when you take a little break and you
come back and you like you shoot the
guns again any throw your abilities
they're like yeah this game still damn
it it's a lot of fun like so it's nice
to have those little spaces just to get
you a little refresher box just pushing
his agenda y'all anything I am NOT for
this I've been on the record I want my
hobby game this sucks
like oh I'm not I'm not about to I have
not about this oh I don't need this we
don't need to rehearse this but I was
like I but I was like but all I want to
say is just like sometimes it's okay to
clear your head of something so when you
come back it's a little refreshed just
oh yeah we would have four weeks of
clearing I'm gonna be fresh and then
you'll have time to play the revision
rate and then when you come back for
opulence you'll be rejuvenated a little
bit so drip drip drip it's not like
stepping away as the end of the world
Jesus
listen I want my hobby gay I want my I
want my full life full-time job game
alright this is what I like to do is my
happy place why are you taking my drugs
run ticket away it's just you can't
always expect something new to get
tacked on yes I can no you can't you
need realistic expectations for the
developers no they need to do better
they need to do better it's not no
really they need to do better this is
trash trash trash trash and they talked
about three weeks before they could fix
something that shouldn't have been in a
PvP event or we bout to go with us but
we last wherever you may rematch right
now okay what other games match
destinies like whether it is the DLCs or
the annual passes what are the game
seven continue to keep you engaged this
long at some point but she has to be
able to take a breath okay how much
brough you want this but we want two
more months laughs you want like it
won't depends on what size of content
we're going for I told you honestly as
we keep hearing about PS 5 and what its
gonna do in 2020 like there's a point
where it's like if they low-key maintain
this thing like for a little while if it
was another like annual pass or like a
mini front-loaded like rise of iron with
a little drip feed stuff over the season
for them to be like and and honestly
like I know there's a point where I know
you're not a fan of that and I know a
lot of people really like the bigger
stuff so if you get say it's a rise of
iron in September and then you give them
the 9 months of drought until say
destiny 3 however and they do it whether
its annual whether it's mini rise of
iron whatever version they have it
I just want Luke Smith to come on camera
specifically like some high person up
there and say this is what we're working
on as a studio we want you guys to enjoy
this piece of content we know it's not
everything that you guys have come to
expect migrant you know and but what we
want to do is take this time and focus
on whatever or and just come out and lay
the plan because right now it's just a
huge question mark of what comes next
yeah and it's like a given if 90% of the
studio is working on d3 tell us at least
let us know that's what you're doing
if rise of iron is coming in any
situation yeah yeah but it's like or if
it's like hey we do want to put out
something we know like the annual passes
maybe not as well received
want to give you guys a dump of stuff in
September we'll have a live team give
you guys some a few live events here and
there so I mean that's kind of thing for
you if you get your rise of iron in
September and you don't get an annual
pass are you are you okay waiting till
say hello I'm asking like where is your
line that it's like if you get your rise
of iron when do you expect something
else because that's your perfer that's
what you prefer you want your comet but
potentially even if it's not comment
your mini comment of like rise of iron
if you get that in September when do you
want something else if I get a rise of
iron in September yep right and then
they come out at the top of 2020 and say
hey you know All Hands are on deck for
destiny three you know this is when we
plan on releasing it and then you set
the community up with expectation as to
why there is drought right yep this
current structure they're trying to
finesse us they're trying to act like oh
my God look at this roadmap look at all
these things
it's arc week and it's revelry and it's
fluff and it's BS it's it's nothing
substantial you yourself just laughed at
our week you yourself which is not
really enthused by none of this revelry
stuff so again this to me demo seasonal
events are pretty lackluster to me
anyway not like this this is the worst
this is the worst they gave it literally
they give us an exotic and tell us to go
away they give us you know a one-week
event and tell you to go away it's
literally just trying to hold us off
this is time gating man it's just it's
bad business and then it's very not
inclusive because then they're making
you buy the annual pads like safe we
didn't buy say if we like you I don't
like this right you're not getting any
of that new stuff you're not getting it
let's say you want it you're not getting
you made you get that the center box
updates it's just it's a sad sad times
man
it's really sad it's sad right now for
me that again do I expect every you know
every week everything of course there's
gonna be down times I know that I'm not
gonna be you know unrealistic but it
this just is so
MZ is so weak it's this I've never seen
a city like this sent back to my
question if not an annual pass if not
this like hey here's a little bit here
and there until we get to what maybe
we're working on if you get a rise of
iron
what if d3 is not September what if it's
like February 2021
I don't think that affects it see we're
going back into our fundamental dip but
the the idea of that it's one or the
other you know I'm saying it's like I
just don't subscribe to it I just think
it's it's it comes it just comes down to
transparency with your base tell your
base what's going on right right now
they're acting like they're giving us
content me and you both know as a man if
you want to put a gun to your head this
is not substantial content this is not
there's just the facts of it right so
now we come into potential September
where again we may get another Annual
Pass we shall see you and I'm saying and
there's just no enthusiasm there's no
enthusiasm to continue forward and and
it just you're putting so much stock on
you know wait wait wait
they do it you know you have to have
that d3 right if they're not maintaining
that some type of a level of quality and
like what confidence do you have that
when d3 happens it's definitely gonna be
this home run it's definitely gonna be
when they're not establishing levels of
decency now they're not even giving us
vendor refreshes we haven't got enough
vendor refresh I don't want to hear
about all resources for a vendor refresh
like come on it's just a little things
they're slacking now so I don't know I'm
very concerned very concerned man did
this this type of structure you know
maybe maybe when the redacted comes out
I get to eat my words and they they have
this juicy content and it's nice but for
now it's tough it's tough out here man
it's it's really tough gotta be honest
no I mean I was like and I'm not
those points I'm really not arguing
that's really not what I'm getting to
but it's some that's why I've been like
what's the answer to your question like
how far is okay so if you get your
preferred chunk that you enjoy yeah you
get a taking King then you have a
holiday goof I'm an awesome forsaken
awesome large pieces of content not a
disease develop but if they do focus on
that then when what if they say hey we
get we want to give you guys this this
is gonna be coming out in September this
is their little announcements say like
pre post e3 whatever they want to do
okay no and then if they say that and
they say okay then September's coming
we're gonna work on d3 till it's ready
this is what will give you the light and
that's it you're good no matter how long
if it's like a year and a half perfect
because they told me right now they're
they're acting like we have content but
we don't have content and we still don't
know what's going on there's no that
there's still this lack of communication
I think that's always been their
Achilles heel right they just they
always struggle with communicating with
the base on what's exactly going on and
and they have to do something about that
if long as you just be transparent and
say this is what's happening you know
and we're gonna get into the division
we're gonna get into to anthem and stuff
like that coming up and see how they're
handling stuff it's just it's how to do
better
they've got answer my question so you're
telling me like if they say hey
September you're gonna get your Comet
check and then until dusty three is
ready even if we delay it to like March
of 2021 like we're going you're okay
with that so okay okay so then you have
then you have a drought of nothing you
have your fountain you know you're gonna
burn through in September and you're
gonna tell me like six months after rise
of iron - you're okay with nothing new
between now as opposed to I'm just
asking if you are the cool yeah that's
all I'm asking if you are them you know
I'm absolutely absolutely I'm okay with
a big comet in September say springtime
you do some light you do you know be a
they doing now right which is the
referee this that right your tiny live
events but so you just get the dawning
crimson days the revelry on solstice and
that's all you get so end it with the
solstice of heroes this is what we did
we stopped call
in September they're like hey we want to
delay destiny 3 until March of 2021 know
it there's no 2021 it's good of there's
good game I'm so this is where I'm
saying what in the unit so that's why
you sit there and you'd be like hey
these live events I'm like what if they
literally give you comment and they stop
like they'll have the live demos like
it's impossible no no I'm saying what
I'm asking you the what-ifs like you
said you're like okay so if I do rise of
iron and you said yeah I'm okay waiting
I was like a year and a half of new
york' and then you turn around and you
say you want this and this and this so
it was like it is just one of those
things you're like I do want the comment
but I also want the live service but do
you I mean no they could literally give
me comment and give me nothing as long
as they told me at the top of 2020 yo
nothing's come in All Hands are on deck
for the next generation consoles for d3
shoutout the game of what they said damn
I'm late I see you guys still agree on
the same as always
PS five comes out in September and then
they're like hey maybe not September but
you've got maybe they're like maybe it's
not ready and this is the point where
Bungie gets to make that call and be
like maybe it's not gonna be at launch
but if you want to wait til January
February let the holidays call down
we're gonna launch into destiny 3 in
February of 2021 cool and if the year
they're upfront with that that's all
I've been trying to ask is like if you
write that break and that's what I would
this is why I was like your side on my
side annual past content yeah a little
big whatever I just want the
transparency and I think you and I
definitely gotta say that we both agree
not to know the like hey man All Hands
are on deck for d3 cool just illustrate
yeah just don't don't not tell me why
you can't do a vent refresh don't not
tell me why you can't fix a gun in a PV
I mean why you can't fix this PvE glitch
in a PV be competitive you know it's
just why why for the whole month of May
we don't see one event going on the
transition transition us between this
and opulence you know I'm saying so I
won't pose in my favor for today thank
you for asking
Oh honestly I'm not surprised on that
one but there's a caveat to say now and
this is where you said you always say
resources
don't matter if they do and if I did
that poll again and say if you got comet
it pushes d3 farther out I don't think
that no I'm sayin if they do not okay
what they were able to put out before
when you had forsaken they had two other
Studios they had hi moon and they had
Vicarious Visions to help with the
content they got Vicarious Visions is
making season of opulence so when you're
all here's that here's the thing to that
whole argument I'm not buying
you're acting like d3 what d3 was in
development with d2 was launched saying
it's not but how didn't he I know but
these other two that have had a short
development cycle mm-hmm
have had some issues so it's it's just
like I don't I don't even feel it had
become listen let's be real d2 wasn't
that it was it a quality product they
made a philosophical change to a to
cater to casual gamers that's their call
they blew that on their own
let's if you look at the content in
itself Leviathan the story the game
itself was good they just made a stupid
decision to say oh we're gonna count
cater to this mass that we don't know
about him you know make it to these
people who eliminate our hard core that
was the issue if they would literally
launch d2 with all the features of d1 we
wouldn't even have this discussion so
I'm not buying that d2 was rushed
they made a tactical error that's the
issue so I'm not gonna hear this all the
resources and they can't do it stop
holding their hands this is a grown
studio this ain't no indie studio this
ain't no little devolver digital this is
Bungie this is a huge company bro stop
holding it home to the fire they can
give us a comment and give us in 2020 a
gam d3 I'm not gonna let this go man I'm
not letting it go you you acting like
this some small little rinky-dink studio
it's not nobody employees they got bro
they've been working on d3 since this
thing launched since the to launch Luke
Smith has been in a in a cave somewhere
they're monogamous ever so it's like I
know that's what you want another huge
studio but I'm just asking if it
does take that if they give you comet if
they give you that piece if you're that
size if that made them like hey if we're
gonna put the Reese's towards this it's
going to push d3 farther and usually
it's not which is fine but if it did is
that would that be something that you
would rather trade a comet for a a
sooner d3 if that was actually some if
you had to make that trade not saying if
they have six thousand employees or
fifty which I'm sure they probably have
easily more than five hundred but again
all those pieces and artists and
everything else like if you had to make
the call would you rather have a comet
in a later d3 or would you'd rather have
something smaller and a suit which game
which do you look forward to more do you
look forward to comet or do you look
forward to d3 more I don't think I think
the issue that we you will always have
is I don't think that it has that
relationship that it has to be one or
the other I really don't I think that's
where we we break I understand where
you're going with it but I still think
that it's it's possible to do that you
know I'm saying and I know your argument
is resources my argument is studio side
and that they're just not that an entity
that can't do it yes I do understand
vicarious is not there with the PC stuff
and all that I get that you know I'm
saying but at the end of the day they
can literally say hey comment at the end
of the year
yo we give you the update on d2
tentative September 2020 you know I'm
saying I get it now let's say you get
close to 2020 right I'll give you Europe
right you say you get close to September
2020 like yeah it's not ready yet
right they can literally give us and say
hey and you'll pass because we're still
working on this for this and then boom
you're gonna get at the top of 2021 I I
think that as long as they communicate
where they are in stages abilities my
point is that you always feel like you
have to have something and that's why
I'm saying if it's the know at some
point okay know if you get your comment
and if they're working on d3 so say you
get both your wishes but then they say
hey d3 we're not ready it's good we you
know we're like three or four months out
it's not gonna be ready for the holidays
we want to do it in February at this one
weird
gonna focus down the live service team
is just gonna like maintain what's left
in d2 about four or five months and then
you might get D three if you don't get
anything in those four or five months is
that's something you're okay with I'm
fine with that as long as they're
transparent okay so long as do that all
right
that's what I keep asking if you get
your comment and then there's this like
16 month break then and then d3 if they
say what's going on to be 16 most I'm
pushing it into 2021 that's how I'm
getting that first year but if that is
what happens then that's what I'm asking
so C for take comment in 2019 destiny 3
2021 that's fine for me and that's again
if we get a bigger piece and if it does
force it to be pushed that's why that's
all that's literally most like my whole
point of this whole thing
where everybody loves the comments
because they're bigger they're a bigger
chunk or and if you take a break you
might go play something else but if
there's a point where you get like a
September or you get a time where there
is nothing cuz they don't have the
activision hell or high you know hold
their feet to the fire it is September
for them you know whatever if you have
that push they have that freedom no I
get it I get it the main thing is
consistency transparency you can't run a
live save service game and have
tremendous gaps without communicating
with your base right that this is a live
service game this is just what this is
this is what we are so you know as long
as I communicate that and I still think
they can do their annual pass stuff
because at the end of the day no one's
gonna convince me that what we're
getting right now is maximum effort then
what we're getting right now is so hard
for them to do and put together I'm not
trying to disrespect any developer I'm
not trying to act like I know how to
make content all I'm trying to say is
the current state that we're in is so
lackluster is so weak it's so flimsy
it's so time gated right that there's no
way you can tell me this is quality
content that guys are working hard
like I'm just I just can't buy that
based on what's going on now if that's
the case then and we're getting this and
they're because they're working on d3 d3
gotta be ready cuz this trash that's
going on right now
you you clearly not using all hands on
deck right now you're saying if you get
another sd3 we gotta be lit now that's
how I'm looking at because you can't
even update a game because of grenade
buffs in the revelry you can't even tell
me what's going on for a whole May
that's why I'm trying to say they can do
both they're clearly not focusing on d2
right now so they're doing something
would be 3 that's 1 trying to say d3 is
not as far out it's gonna be as delayed
as we think that's all I'm saying if
you're saying September is gonna be like
new console launch now you're giving me
annual pass again I don't want to hear
about no denying with that like no past
and be like hey we're getting this load
maintenance it's a front-loading annual
pass we're shooting for like we want to
go new consoles so here's the question
drifter yeah do you want d3 to be cross
generation or do you just want it on ah
good question just like dude on next-gen
consoles and PC though my prediction
that is going to be cross generation
because the article that came out with
um the play state with Sony blocking the
cross progression from new PC and Xbox
and all that stuff here's the thing when
any new generation starts just like d1
right it was on Xbox 360 and PlayStation
3 yep right so they're not gonna abandon
what is it 80 million PlayStation 4 90
you know 42:35 Xbox ones a brand new
place a PC base they're not going to
abandon it so this is coming out on the
weight the way these consoles are gonna
be they're gonna be scalable PlayStation
4 and Xbox will be the lower end and
your high end PC you know Connor
experience will be what PlayStation 5
and Xbox Scarlett or whatever it is and
they'll have that transfer and
especially especially now that the
Activision stuff is over because that
will end the Sony exclusivity deal and
hopefully well they definitely because
wave splitter we already seen what
you've been getting that right yeah
big-time
that's like the less it should be we
open yeah exactly so their contracts
with Activision so there's no doubt
they're gonna be fine man they're gonna
be finest
is gonna be able to to be scalable on
certain levels now yeah it's gonna look
phenomenal in the new consoles but yeah
I definitely think that but yeah if they
if what the rumors are which is they
come out with the annual pass again
there's no excuse to me there's no
excuse based on cadence and what's in
effort can you imagine
honestly a like a lunch like destiny
being a next-gen launch title though
okay like that would be I mean it would
be a big question I was like can you
imagine that actually being like hey
we're out and it within I don't know a
week maybe two first month timing of
like PS 5 is I don't know what are they
like late October early November is when
they seem to do consoles yeah like do
you put yourself in that place it's a
good question I mean it comes down to
one if the game is ready in the game me
but you know des T's been around a block
enough that it's a lot of pressure to
launch what a new console no doubt
there's no doubt I will say this as as
an xbox Fred um I we got some tidbits
recently because you know Microsoft with
the whole X cloud and screaming and with
the mice and stuff now
i'ma let y'all know right now Phil
Spencer is a huge destiny fan you know
I'm saying and I will tell he's been
testing destiny cuz you know like they
had like the the X thing and then they
got like the phone with the controller a
bit and they're doing that cloud as an
option he's been testing destiny in
Japan remotely on this thing through arm
X cloud I wouldn't be surprised if they
tried to drop a money bag off not that
they're gonna do the exclusivity with
the exotics and the maps yeah but like
the marketing deal
remember how Sony at least just had the
marketing deal just show it on our stage
right it's still cross-platform still
everywhere else I wouldn't be surprised
your destiny is still a hot commodity
that they would want the back and Phil
Spencer is the type that he's not about
locking content he said this money time
a lot of Xbox fans get mad at this cuz
when Xbox guys get the marketing deal
they be like you know we should get
exclusive like how Sony got it he's like
now I don't believe in the content and
stuff like that look at division they
technically have the marketing deal with
that they don't do that kind of stuff
you don't say unlock PlayStation guys I
could seen them drop in the bag off in
that bag good substantial Amani could go
to Bungie and help them what they gotta
do I could see that I wouldn't be
surprised I wouldn't be surprised
should be interesting I mean but yeah
it's like it should be interesting cuz I
mean as what Forte's basically and ps5
the rumors out there for like March of
2020 which feels early for me for a copy
of what I mean
switch launched in March and it's doing
okay so I mean I don't know and that's
kind of the whole gaming landscape with
like III changing and being less
relevant because you have games
launching all year long
you have right it's not as much of the
holiday push because you have some big
games to just say I'm not gonna go fight
against your Call of Duty's or your Red
Dead so your main holiday push I'm gonna
go find some space at my own time and
still be just as successful division
anthem if it wasn't broken
right but I mean like there sure like
anthem there's too many words out there
at 11,000 plus written other issues with
that but that timing is now making III
less of a main like market at e3 launch
at September fight to do the holidays
like you have the spread so I mean if
ps5 did go March of 2020 then it's a
completely separate issue I'd be
surprised and it did because you've got
only reason for it say I probably
wouldn't say ps5 because they're looking
at the rise in 3000 series chips those
are this into architecture and that's
they're supposed to launch in July and
if you don't even give like a year for
the pricing and the production and the
build of those for the prices of the
chips themselves to come down to make
the system more affordable you're
looking into the higher price point so
the longer they push it out the older
the architecture and the technology gets
and therefore the price could actually
be lower so between na'vi which isn't
even out yet not even announced being on
that system and then rises into being
the main platform that think things
built on my hunch is probably gonna be
like more towards that September October
November giving those some more time to
get it revealed because I haven't even
seen a day for not yet and that's
supposed to be on there is he's killing
me Val he's killing me but no I mean
that's what it is I mean we'll see what
happens I definitely generation I think
I think we do get our progression I
think that a PC and Xbox and in common
peace
consoles in general we'll get to play
together I think that's happen because
those documents that came out that was
what Bungie vision was so when I see
stuff like that prior to solid yeah they
want that that really resonates for me
that makes me feel good that that's
something they were pushing for so we
got that and then um you know we'll see
what happens but I'm excited you know at
the end of the I know I'm complaining
now I I'm I'm confident in the three I
really I really I I know you you you're
like yo this is a lot of pressure they
got to do it right I get your sentiment
you're not wrong on that
I'm confident though I think they know
they've been around the block to know
that d2 was them over playing their hand
getting what I call it is them getting
too cute they got cute right they they
had they did everything they need to do
d1 is how can we get that Arthur gamer
who doesn't have all the time right to
play destiny and get it in and uh and it
was okay well let's do this and let's do
that and then the guy to gain kind of
bit but um I think once forsaken hit
they realized that problem was daddy
Activision was fighting back cuz they
want astronomical money even though it
did well you know I'm saying and then
they like okay you know what let's take
our baby back we don't like these dudes
over here you go your way we go our way
we like what we got and they're gonna be
fine man I'm confident in them boys man
every time one thing about destiny when
the back is to the wall damn movin every
single time yo we can make a quality
game we can give you what you want and
the fact that they still flying these
guys out there I'm like okay they're not
cocky
they still listening let's see what
happens but yeah big d3 is gonna be fine
but I was like that you're missing
things for d3 that I hope like different
engines so they can be more responsive
on stuff like this lore like you know
changes or something breaks and all
those types of things definitely stuff
that like the engine may be good if they
go more on the RPG stuff if there's
light Burt verse dark if there's any of
these rumors in there it's got potential
to be amazing as long as they as long as
they like you know put it all together
learn from the last lake basically it's
gonna be six years by the time the thing
comes out
frickin amazing so no believe me I'm
like like d3 is the one I'm gonna be
like look I don't do I have a job can I
quit my job just so I can cover d3 like
that's gonna be the point where a d3
would just be like alright this is this
is the one we're gonna be living here
for a while so absolutely alright yeah I
mean for destiny we've got iron banner
coming next week which is gonna be fine
I mean they said the they they said the
iron burden it's going away he's not
coming back it's only gonna be a season
six experiment the wizened rebuke you're
still gonna have two more times to earn
it so if you're working for that one
there's some crazy emblem out there if
you get twenty five hundred burdened
kills there's an ornament out there I
think we're gonna have the rocket
launcher and I don't know which one it
is I think if the pulse rifle the rocket
launcher that can't run with cluster
bombs and track it yeah that we can
actually okay okay got one actually oh
you've got out you got a reservoir yeah
I'm in trouble
the curator definitely can oh it's a
curated okay cool go I didn't see I
correctly so rocket launcher it's the
Scout of the polls so forget which one
it is
that's the Scout that looks like like
quick touch I just want to get your
thoughts just cuz I want to give us a
little time and a time spectral blades
these are the things that are gonna
change let's go I don't know win mmm-hmm
maybe it's after the rebel rebel get
this one out but it's another three
weeks the damage reduction out of
stealth is gonna be reduced some 60% to
52% in stealth damage reduction from 62%
to 54% quick brief they say previously
the super had the highest damage damage
reduction of all the roaming sumers
shocking either in stealth or not this
change reduces spectre blades to have
the lowest damage reduction of all the
roaming supers while stealth is not
active and to be in line with the low
end while stealth is active while
stealth vision through walls and fast
shifty movement no kidding it's still a
pain in the butt to ever killem the
super ability can actually have a lot of
built-in survivability this means lower
dam reduction means better planning for
those attacks but one that means more is
the super duration super length out of
stealth with no attacking is down three
seconds super length in style
with no attacking is also down three
seconds from 26 to 23 with stealth you
have 23 seconds that is a long time to
cover half a map basically if you don't
attack it so I mean these last time it's
not insanely long amount of time they
did this is the one that's gonna help
though because they said light melee and
cost increased 50% now they said it
wasn't that high in the first place but
basically you won't be able to travel
that way I guess as easily it's gonna be
a little more costly to do so so running
in stealth and then swiping as opposed
to swipe swipe swipe swipe swipe to
cover ground is gonna be a thing they
said they're also looking at go eyes and
best playing with some changes on that
one if we decide to change quite and
you'll see it in season 7 so guys I
won't change for later this one might be
coming whenever they fix the other stuff
with revelry so what do you think real
quick on that one good bad run quiz it
it not all I'm gonna tell you what this
is my real quicker synapses
this is probably a very light touch but
they are scared that they don't want to
Nova warp it I kind of figured that's
all this is stayed so what they're doing
is okay they know they messed up
wouldn't let's cut touch take it back a
little let's not kill the super
completely and they're gonna see how it
is and then they'll adjust again so
that's all I got quizzing I'm a nervous
little bit about that I want to see how
to ask on play yeah I mean and I do I
think you made the point with the light
melee attack being what it was you know
I'm saying like they needed to make that
energy cost higher right so let's just
see how I play see how it plays out I'm
willing to give them a pass on this one
I know they take along with this but um
you know I they there on that Lee you
know not bringing out the full ban
hammer nuking it to death kind of fob
and I gotta respect that a little bit so
where you I know I think you're pretty
much nail on the head no I think you
nailed it
butts dealt in the damage reduction if I
can nail a super in the face with my
hammer it still gets annoying that some
of those don't die but I guess they're
roaming ones have such a reduction it's
just annoying that I feel like I take a
Don blades flying sword and I die as a
Titan but I hit them into square in the
face with a hammer and they don't die so
yeah that's always frustrating to me
just because I love my hammers the super
duration it's insanely long I did not
know is that long
go I isn't making it longer the
mainly cost hopefully giving a little
more thought before you swipe to cover
ground I mean it seems as you're saying
they don't want to over nerve so they're
kind of taking it light and but again as
it's taken this long if they don't do it
enough then how much longer do have to
wait till they fix it so we'll see yeah
I mean yeah it's a light touch for this
point I go front I know Franny when I
hate our spectral blade sound I just run
horrified I seriously yes run terrified
but outside of that they got a couple
other things shout outs a bunch II still
do an awesome donation work so if you
got any questions after that they've got
some cool prizes like the one that I
wish I just added like a thousand
dollars - for once support the charities
because they're always awesome but you
get all the above prizes plus
participate in the bungy studio visit
with you and two guests mmm that'd be
awesome
like yeah you gotta fly yourself out
there but if you had a thousand dollars
to donate to a cause and you get to go
get a studio like that's one of those
things I'd love to ever get invited but
if not it be on yeah so you got some
money rolling around and you feel like
supporting some movie support then
absolutely go check out their uh their
charities and stuff like that absolutely
that pretty much wraps up destiny guys
for the week quick run-through for the
next piece I'm gonna let you lead off on
that one I've heard a little bit of kind
of streams and things being broken and
delays and just kind of where we are
right now what are we doing yeah I mean
well right now the latest they had that
a title update you know and now they
going through the balancing right now
and the basically long short of it is
that they are delayed and I saw a
snippet of that Zach what'd you say they
look like they're delaying the raid okay
so yeah so basically right now you know
their whole thing is they want to get
the balance tab and there's a couple of
things that they really want to affect
and I'm okay with that
I'm literally okay with that and the
cool thing what they're doing it I think
that but actually Bungie needs to take
advantage of is they're opening a public
test server on the PC version so nice
yeah man first of all ABS hello you know
I'm saying the plan is to structure you
know the pts and stage is called a test
server say each lasting a few days and
focusing on a specific part of the game
we will have surveys and dedicated forum
threads together with our traditional
general and technic
issues for him to cover these topics so
they said that now that it's live it
will include every piece of new content
coming in the title update to eat except
for the raid and they said that although
the rate is a major piece of the new
content they said the patch also
implements them several talent buffs and
nerfs as well what I like about this eat
is they know how important this rate is
for them oh and I can't watch it they
can't watch it and I love the caution to
make sure bounces right whether it's PvE
whether it's your all-time favorite dark
zone your the PvP whatever you gotta do
make balance this thing get it right
there's no need to rush out a raid when
the actual meta of the game may not be
at its best I'm all for that you know I
mean so I mean that's pretty much what
it is or on this thing you know nothing
too crazy you know I'm Aldo and dizzy
right now Larry said they are inspiring
your chat right that's all I know
it's a letter it's just kind of not
touching it yeah I'm now movies gonna
let them let them battle it out here's a
question for you we are what's up we're
about a month from lunch right was it
like marketing through something like
that okay yeah yes so you get this is a
different aspect of missus I don't know
if it's fire team chat might have been
talking about this the time separation
from launch and they kind of where they
like stagger the tears in the head tr5
come out the time versus the launch
versus the rape and something like the
raid race the special nature of the
people who grind it out the ones who are
ready for it right versus this one where
most people are and this is kind of an
interesting thought
you have the hype of the game come out
you have division to launch people are
getting up to like close to mass spec
maybe they like work on tier four maybe
they're getting up to tier five if you
keep delaying this raid does for you on
the other side like when the raid
launches you think people be like hey I
got up to max and I'm gonna go play
something like do you think this is too
long do you like how Bungie does like
the three days for the little stuff like
it was ten days [ __ ] forsaken and
that's a quick heart push and not
everybody can get there versus you know
make it a month and a half for
or however long everybody gets up there
and then that raid race is a much
broader audience which one do you prefer
soon although I decided what do you
think um listen I'm all about balance
I've always been that way though you
know saying like it the proper thing is
I think let's just be really like with
the way a destiny raid is constructed
it's just different you know I'm saying
so it's not like apples to apples kind
of a deal yeah I don't look at it and
let's be honest they never something
they've really doing new they've been
unlocking tears
they've been unlocking strongholds
that's been their back you know saying
this is some whole new thing do I like
that is delayed no obviously of course I
want to play the raid like of course I
want to experience what this thing is
you know I'm saying but a rather studio
err on the side of caution
with the one of their biggest content
and be transparent about it you know I'm
Sam like that's my thing like yo you
letting me know why it's not happening
this is what's going on and the day I
had the video out with um the state of
the game thing I like the I wish other
companies with a follow
said soon you know this so I'm ready for
it man I'm ready for it and um like I
said I already heard some leaks about
how it's gonna be and you know we were
we kind of little spoil of that but they
will be separated sections which is dope
is not going to be eight players in a
room on a horrible dizzy so it's gonna
be late and on yeah like at the end of
the day like I'm not worried about what
clowns say because other clowns were
investing in a game that I told them was
gonna lose to this game
dizzy and you still I got the receipts
on you so I'm going in on you now you
let I'm putting the boot on yo neck
right now dizzy so I don't wear anything
he talked about is this the man that bet
on another game to beat division that
came out around the same time when I
told him what was gonna happen
so anyway I'm done being petty at the
end of the day listen do I want it yes
you know Sam but right now they got it
they gotta fix these things they got
they got to get that thing out there and
then when it comes to comes I'm cool
with it
division is such a good place right
there right back like go for it yeah
division is in the outside we talked
about
oh this would be the roast dizzy section
shout through the jet gel smell though I
want him now now he gets my full
undivided attention now the end of the
day man this is such a good place right
now
people having so much fun with division
right now they cool they chill they got
they feet up right now
you got worry about your game right now
that we gonna talk about next
that they don't got the internet for
let's talk about the game that right now
the internet went out if they could do a
stream and they okay can't tell us what
the Cataclysm Orleans now bro anthem was
which you you had your palm palms out I
with the same energy you had two months
ago and I couldn't stop hearing from you
Oh Yvonne sees a back okay I guess not
rose tonight yes oh my roast dizzy
section cuz like a Snell doe said some
people it's taken too long they're kind
of losing interest the people who do
grind it hard and if they're waiting for
like hey I got to tier four five isn't
that much different I mean it's gonna be
a little higher score like kind of that
magic would be it's like not everybody
can know life it feel like the first
week but if you go six weeks seven weeks
like if you almost go like two months
depending on how long it goes you get to
a point where some people be like I've
kind of hit the end like that next piece
of content isn't there it's like that
the magic window I wish would be like
three weeks for all these things just
because like you'd give people a little
time you're still within that first
month of launch not everybody's gonna
know life at the no lifers are gonna get
up there so I mean there are things to
do but in general it's like that the
timeframe on this one seems and it's
kind of an interesting thing to watch
it's like how many stick around on the
other side of it so bright you got bugs
you like full high up every go buddy go
in no life and then you know it's there
and then the other side it's like
they're taking their time and they they
know they have to do this one right as
you said there's there's no question
there first raid like their first
competition into this whole bungees been
doing these rates for a long time we've
got to try and actually try and answer
this we got to do it 100% right like
there's no way they're like they're
nervous there's no way they're not
because it's already feel like they have
to be like they're basically not do like
they'd be just
but the way I'm looking at it is no no
disrespect the division bungees just the
goal when it comes to like certain
aspects of game design the mechanics and
gun play you just got to give it up
and I'm saying and it doesn't matter
what division do does or certain things
so you know their best effort yeah it's
probably gonna be good with when they
finally get it comes out but you know I
don't there's levels to this you're
saying like this Bungie is always gonna
be here when it comes to certain things
they're gonna try to do the best they
can do in their space in that realistic
tactical space no I'm saying that's it
and I accept it for what it is but um I
mean that's pretty much all I got on
anything I want to talk about no we got
much time but only one I want to get
into the anthem stuff since Dizzy's here
we got to talk about anthem yeah so I
mean they were supposed to do a live
stream apparently their fiber line got
cut somehow I didn't dig too far into
this one I don't know if you dug deep on
it
well I dug deep what happened that's
like the brief of what I got so they
were gonna delay their stream well till
next week so I'm with um let me stop it
now real it's it's really cuz um at the
end of the day you know they had the
roadmap and you know we had um I believe
what was the name of this thing they had
the sunken I was supposed to drop in
April we still don't have no you know
timeframe is to that a lot it basically
this was supposed to be the explain
what's going on
you know the fiber cut so they couldn't
do this dream they had a backup line to
do it but apparently when it was tested
it was too shaky to do the livestream
they were having all type of problems
with uh you know with that and um now
everything's in jeopardy shot the poet
as he would his latest article because
you know not as the sunken is in
complete danger of dropping in April and
then my personal thing which really hurt
me is the Cataclysm because you know at
the end of the day when is that like we
don't know what it is still we know it's
their in-game content yeah you know I'm
saying but it's just like you know I
mean it's wait wait wait what is it
gonna be when is it gonna come out so
now it just seems like everything else
now is just push back and it sucks
because they kind of needed a boost of
good news of just to say hey what's been
working on what's going on kind of thing
and I listen as much as I joke
I'm clowning yeah I know I like anything
I want this game I love Iowa I want them
to succeed I don't want them to die I
don't want them to be out of here you
know we know what happened with the um
you know the the Jason fryer article
that leaked the culture of the studio
how is development hell no wait hold on
I gotta get on he trying to run away
from anthem ain't my bag no you had your
pom-poms out sir we're not gonna do that
we're not gonna do I have the video tie
got the receipts but you're not gonna
back away back you're gonna own this you
gonna hold this el and you're gonna wear
it proudly now you're gonna talk about
the road to recovery for you basically
they've got it they got to reinvest they
gotta listen to what the cool thing
about the Schreyer expose is it showed
indecision on bio where it showed the
stage waited like what it's five six
years they couldn't do this lit you know
what it really showed me it really
wasn't EA as much as I thought it was
some pieces but by over had a lot of
pieces to it like right yeah only thing
I give ei is e a had frostbite right and
frostbite they want to push on people
because they're being cheap you don't
want to pay for an unreal engine all
right so I get that now here's the
mistake they made by West says oh let's
be proactive and switch to it so we can
learn it now right the difference
between them and a respawn is look what
Reese one did with the titanfall 2 and
the apex they didn't switch there's no
those are not on frostbite those stayed
with unreal doing what they know and
it's just sad it's just really sad then
you had the whole Casey leaving and
Casey coming back it's just you know the
good thing I will say this the good
thing about expose is like that is that
everyone sees your business everyone
sees your skirt you know I'm saying as
far as what's going on in an inning in
your house it's out there they know they
have to change you know I'm saying the
question is you know obviously is it
gonna be enough and the way I envisioned
it which is what I predicted it's gonna
be a situation where and someone towards
the end that it'll be like how Division
one played out
that's what I honestly expect they need
to do 0.8 they need to yeah be quiet for
a while they need to basically develop
what they want and basically also be
developing anthem to at the same time
yeah it's not oh I got a discrete you
buddy I don't think it was on
800% hey buddy you got to read that
Jason Schreyer stuff there are certain
things because I talked my brother about
it too because he's a huge fan I mean
there are points where it's like I mean
anthem having not being called anthem
before the launch of like III and 2017
is insane like not having a name the
fact that they wouldn't talk they
literally and this is what we like by
ORS like they would not acknowledge the
world destiny you could not say the word
oh but I mean that's that's one of those
were people like the ideal ever some
people like the reviews were saying it
was developed in a bubble and you
literally see those words and you're
like it was so they mean there's things
like that where it's like a fear to talk
about another game and not learn from
them there's like nowhere there was
flying that wasn't flying there was
flying like those type of giant game
changes much less like having it called
beyond and then not being able to get
the trademark and having to create lure
for anthem it's like the writers the
creators like the programmers building
systems that like I mean it's been like
six months I'm like a flying system then
you dump it and then you gotta be like
six months later then you gotta go
create it again it's like mm-hmm
so it's like the big I just want to like
but on EA side like they they said I
mean they said they're using frostbite
they I think that push was actually from
EA and then even my brother was telling
me when he dug deep as well like when it
comes to like the engine mechanics like
frostbite like I'm building the engine
to work for your game there were
specific engineers that were like
frostbite engineers and he said at one
point EA ripped their FIFA yes so that's
not he is like EA did screw them to a
point of like well the people who are
literally building the base level code
in an engine to work out your game right
this EA like EA ribs to FIFA and that's
like that's a huge detriment to do
because they specific engineers which is
like I mean but that's right a piece
where it's like by overhead like so many
scrubs but it's like was it all EA
absolutely not was it all Bioware no and
I honestly probably mean it more towards
Bioware EA had a
had a couple things were like they were
rough but I mean Bioware's like magic
did not go together and that's the point
to where they're learning a hard lesson
and I think as you said and like or my
brother described before like Final
Fantasy 14 or something where they
literally like you shut you can't shut
the game down at this point but they
basically have to pull the Division One
and be like yeah we're not gonna release
much for a while and honestly at this
point I don't even think they should do
Cataclysm I know they probably have to I
know that kind of have to have to but I
don't think it's gonna live up to
anything right now because in three like
what they made in about nine months the
gameplay we have we have like a shell of
like systems of what yeah we have and
how good the flying is in that think
about how late that guy put in I was
like I was amazed right yeah so is like
those like what we have in the game
mechanics-wise is insanely awesome for
the fun part
yeah well you got your appointment yet
people so yeah we got to wrap up mm-hmm
if you want to do your apps I'm gonna do
two seconds and I'll be right back yeah
do your thing I'll talk um yeah here's
the deal dizzy I'm with you on this part
like at the end of the day these guys
had so long to make the game and what
needed to happen was they I don't want
to call it dilly dallying but they were
just so undecisive you know what I'm
saying so I can't blame EA for if I had
to put a ratio on it y'all I'm going 70%
Bioware problem and 30% EA with the
frostbite engine so that's where I'm at
with it you know I definitely think you
know you can't take that long and
develop it you can't be so undecided on
this littlest systems and all these
different things and if flying is gonna
be in a game and if it's not gonna be in
a game that's all Bioware matter these
guys are talking about leaving meetings
and nothing was getting solved it has
nothing to do with EA so no it is what
it is you know sad situation you know
hopefully we get cataclysms we get you
know all this other stuff and they look
at you know destiny look at division
like like the drifter said and then
learn from it and you know put four I
think like I said done being exposed
allows anthem to to really get to where
it needs to be but look and I'm what you
call he's got is a
idea he's got a plan a net fix guys
quick wrap-up gimme ebon to everywhere
twitch Twitter YouTube you guys know
where to find me a stream at home ZB o
and T is it's hard to miss yes yeah
that's probably about to die so you
wanna rap yes sir law Cognito twitter
you already know what is chat has been
late our law podcast is Sunday 1 p.m.
kognito comes back to hosting please
check us I was gonna be fun a lot of fun
topics yo last where it was lit y'all
thank y'all for coming over twitch looks
like this what we gonna do in the
bonta's once he gets to upload going
it's gonna be Scooby's gonna be late
y'all this is a fun one man alright guys
for this week that is the last word the
last word ah hold on try that again
alright so we're gonna do all right
three two one the last word last word
okay our timings terrible we'll work on
that right